yeah welcome a five minute game and hmm
an Enzo and let's see what line yes as
mentioned in some other video i'm
working on a on a book exactly this line
is some featured in the book the huebner
defense or from of the new zone but i am
working on other chapters at the moment
so if i played this like a complete
[ __ ] you can still buy my book yeah
it's a just bad luck it's not the kind
of the system I I haven't haven't looked
at yet okay 91 this might mean two
things regrouping I 2 c 2 e 3 or he
wants to go F form so on I want to
prepare a five if you play some f 4 then
maybe 98 isn't the greatest move ever
but I can see regroup decently okay this
is another idea night g2 but anyways I
want to go f5 I know it looks like I'm
exchanging my good bishop for his
technically bad bishop but um there's
the famous saying good good a bad
bishops protect good points and this d3
Bishop is bad but it protects c4 and
exchanging it off helps me in the long
run to attack the spawn so f5s a typical
way to to handle the serve the structure
yeah I can take I can play Knight f6
what first let's take I mean taking with
the porn yeah he he just went for it
I wanted to say that Liz's looks very
very static and not too attractive but
he nevertheless plated the fun thing is
or the interesting things digitally is
that exchanging all heavy pieces is very
very good for black and then the pawns
get weak on e4 and c4 and try now Bishop
g4 h5 to g6 attacking me for ya are
interesting maybe maybe I need to go
here cannot allow them to to damage my
pawn structure and this in turn makes
Bishop g4 questionable maybe the night
on g6 I obviously cannot transfer the 50
Bishop to g6
ok I want it on g6 though maybe let's
let's go here this is the good news I'm
threatening Knight g4 for example on on
Rogue f2f Oh Nyjah form huh
night to age five how does he answer
this king if we move the King I can take
I can take now takes Queen h4 and takes
you one isn't this working now maybe
it's in secure kind of self trap but ok
let's let's check it takes Queen Queen
edge for check came to age to Queen to
you one and what then Bishop f2 and yeah
it looks that looks weird probably
probably not hmm yeah this makes night
h5 questionable I didn't I didn't
calculate so far but ok it's nothing
nothing bad happened just exchanging
heavy pieces excellent for black I can I
can come on i'm a cheap player i know
but i want to get this idea in and ok he
defended that i can i can just drop back
though so what what's what is the way
how to proceed him the g6 night a son is
a problem peace it doesn't do do
anything how to improve it
yeah it seems that he wants to play
Bishop to h3 I don't mind that radio
okay I don't mind that it doesn't it
doesn't help him so much he still has
got to be pawns and the bishop only
three is technically the good Bishop but
it cannot defend c4 and also naughty for
of course yeah yeah maybe wait not so
quick yeah this is--okay attacking this
the spawn and he needs to do some rules
here this is for example that it
probably doesn't want to play go into
these seven
is he threatening anything g5 yeah
probably i need the Queen back anyway
if seven is probably the better square
yeah all this is nice but he still got
the bed bed structure
yes please manage to to get them get
some counterplay of course but it's not
clear on how effective this is how
interesting cannot I cannot exchange can
go to f1 down yes yeah what is this time
warning
here the time is not great and I'm not
quite sure I think it's a draw but 16
seconds is not not exactly comfortable
who actually safe to draw I'm not quite
sure it doesn't have the time on here
and it more up must be some version
change of the of the system but it must
have been like nothing on the clock I'm
not sure why it doesn't show the the
time anymore yeah but they're safe to
draw getting getting the last four on
the last thing is really at the end well
yeah I sport I sport a substantial I
think a rather substantial advantage
this position is so static that it is
black good for black this is so this is
quite quite clear the only question is
how to how to improve he got he got some
nice counter play on the King side maybe
this is Queen excursion wasn't wasn't
the best or i had i need to improve him
yeah night 2h7 is the computer
suggestion maybe this is good night 2h7
intending to go 2077 228 on edge for
then now yes got enough play to secure
draw
again this is just the draw all the time
the draw and then he actually went back
to to lose the game our position I mean
the game was drawn on time just relax
the last second yeah thanks for watching